hey Don I know Trump has a long list of
accomplishments I wanted to ask you what
do you think his biggest accomplishment
was and then on the flip side his
biggest shortcoming in his first term
oh
biggest accomplishment I mean I guess it
I just look at the the economy was going
so good man you know I guess I I look at
that you know I'm sort of a you know a
that was a blue collar guy sort of
Trapped in New York but I spent all my
weekends with guys up in Northern you
know northeast PA and I shot
competitively hung out with regular guys
and like watching what those guys that
continue to come up to me is like man we
had it so good under your dad like that
meant more to me I mean I think
obviously the North Korea stuff when I
was just baller uh I think the Abraham
Accords like that was the Holy Grail of
geopolitical politics right yes like no
one's going to get a peace deal in the
Middle East we've been crying for
centuries it's like well we got five
it was the Holy Grail of geopolitan it
can't be done